at the risk of uh asking the rolling
stones to play satisfaction let me ask
you about the origin story of instagram
sure
so maybe some context you
like we were talking about offline grew
up in massachusetts
learned computer programming there liked
to play doom 2
worked at a vinyl record store then you
went to stanford
turned down mr
mark zuckerberg and facebook
went to florence to study photography
those are just some random beautiful
impossibly brief glimpses into a life so
let me ask again can you take me through
the origin story of instagram giving
that context you basically set it up um
all right so uh we have a fair amount of
time so i'll go into some detail but
basically what i'll say is
um
instagram started out of a company
actually called bourbon
and it was spelled b-u-r-b-n
and uh a couple things were happening at
the time so if we zoom back to 2010 not
a lot of people remember what was
happening in the dot com world then
uh but
check-in apps were all the rage
so let's checking out uh gowalla four
square hot potato
so i'm at a place i'm gonna tell the
world that i'm at this place that's
right what's what's the idea behind this
kind of app by the way you know what i'm
gonna answer that but through
what instagram became and why i believe
instagram replaced them
so the whole idea was to share with the
world what you were doing specifically
with your friends right
um
but they were all the rage and
foursquare was getting all the press and
i remember sitting around saying hey i
want to build something but i don't know
what i want to build what if i built a
better
version of foursquare
and i asked myself well
why don't i like foursquare or how could
it be improved
um
and basically i sat down and i said i
think that if you have a few extra
features it might be enough one of which
happened to be posting a photo of where
you were
there were some others it turns out that
wasn't enough my co-founder joined we
were going to attack uh you know
foursquare and the likes and and try to
build something interesting
um and no one used it no one cared
because it wasn't enough it wasn't it
wasn't different enough right
so one day we were sitting down and we
asked ourselves okay let's come to jesus
moment
are we going to do this startup
and if we're going to we can't do what
we're currently doing we have to switch
it up so what do people love the most so
we sat down and we wrote out
three things that we thought people
uniquely loved about our product that
weren't in other products
photos happened to be the top one so
sharing a photo of what you were doing
where you were at the moment was not
something
products let you do really facebook was
like post an album of your vacation from
two weeks ago right twitter allowed you
to post a photo but their feed was
primarily text and they didn't show the
photo in line or at least i don't think
they did at the time
so
even though it seems totally
stupid and obvious to us now at the
moment then
posting a photo of what you were doing
at the moment was like not a thing
so
we decided to go after that because we
noticed that people who used our service
the one thing they happened to like the
most was posting a photo
so that was the beginning of instagram
and yes like we went through and we
added filters and there's a bunch of
stories around that but the origin of
this was that we were trying to be a
checking app realized that no one wanted
another checking app
it became a photo sharing app but one
that was much more about what you're
doing and where you are
and that's why when i say i think we've
replaced checkin apps
it became a check-in via a photo rather
than
saying
your location and then optionally adding
a photo
you